in the draft from his brain
originally box underneath an ad on the
LOB tried to put it over the rim and he
gets fouled
21250 Lakers on top or halfway through
this first quarter and again holding his
side was a t-bob way LeBron has a chance
to go and say hello to Kobe who is
sitting in the front row right at
midcourt
there's mr. Bryant his daughter Dianna
is sitting beside it doesn't come out
often but it's a true loyalty of each
does make an appearance there's been
three from st. Joe's their nickname is
hard on a team JaVale McGee
[Applause]
all starts with the tips look at that
bounce pass and JaVale does a great job
of knocking it free and LeBron the
recipient of a three-point play that was
so good even Kobe had to enjoy it he's
been cheering for the Lakers ever since
the opening death sick LeBron just one
behind not for long then he plays to the
crowd again 33 for number 23
115 93 in as many minutes 33 minutes 33
pins and of course Kobe Bryant in
attendance tonight
and LeBron putting on a show what a pass
and the finish by Cruz boy you just have
to keep moving keep moving boy when he
has the ball the chant with the
background
mr. dill
a magnificent Kobe Bryant